Hadi partovi is a tech entrepreneur,
an investor, and the CEO of Education,
nonprofit code.org. Born in Tehran, Iran.
How they grew up during the Iran,
Iraq war is high school,
did not offer computer science classes.
So he taught himself to code at home on
a commodore 64 after immigrating to the
United States.
He has spent his summers working as a
software engineer to help pay his way
through that,
uh,
his college and high school and graduating
from Harvard with a master's degree
in computer science. How they pursue
the Caribbean and technology, uh,
companies like Microsoft word.
He rose to the executory ranks.
He founded two startups. The first one
was a huge success and the second ad,
the small failure. And now he invests
in advisors, other technology startups.
In 2013,
Huddy and his twin brother Ali launched
education nonprofit code.org we had,
Heidi continues to lead
full time as CEO could.
Dot Org has established computer science
classes in 20% of the u s classrooms
created the most broadly used curriculum
platform for k 12 computer science and
launched the global hour of the code
movement that has reached over a hundred
million students.
How'd he has served as an early
advisor or investor at many things,
startups including Facebook,
Dropbox, Airbnb, and Uber.
He currently serves on the board
of directors of Exxon and convey,
so please join me welcoming
Hadi Partovi to speak for us.
Thank you.
Our vision is that every student in every
school should have the opportunity to
learn computer science.
I like probably many of you began
learning on my own at home, which was how,
you know, in the eighties or nineties,
people started learning computer science.
But in the 21st century, this is the field
that everybody should have access to.
Uh, I start my presentations by talking
about why this is important. Uh,
and most audiences have some
inkling of why it's important.
I would expect her Google,
it's,
it's not a very hard pitch to explain
that people should learn computer science,
but some of the statistics behind
it still surprise people who just
automatically believe computer
science should be taught.
There's three reasons for teaching
computer science to students.
One is for economic
opportunity in their careers.
The second is to give them
a well rounded education.
And the third is to help make school fun.
And I want to go into each of
these in a little bit of depth.
So talking about opportunity
is the easiest case for
teaching computer science.
Uh,
computing has become not only the fastest
growing and highest peck paying sector
of wages,
but it's now become the largest sector of
all new wages in the United States. Uh,
and this is not just in California,
in Washington,
it's in every industry in
every single state. Uh,
this is a picture showing the breakdown
of all new wages in the country in
currently open jobs.
So not people who are currently working,
but the opportunity to get hired,
looking at where the salaries are,
the biggest sector is not computing.
This hasn't always been the case.
It's also the fastest growing slice
of the pie. So it's uh, you know,
as we hear about computing work,
automating other jobs,
this is the one part of the job pie
that is actually growing and it's,
it's gradually becoming a larger
and larger slice of the Pie. Uh,
it's also the best paying, uh, area
of, of work in the United States.
In fact,
the,
this graph compares the lifetime earnings
of a high school graduate versus a
university graduate versus a university
computer science graduate. Uh,
the difference between the second two
is almost as big as the first two.
So congrats to all of you here who
are computer science graduates, uh,
to be in that third bucket.
Um,
but the jobs and career opportunities
aren't the only reason to be teaching
computer science. Uh, in the 21st century.
Computer Science is foundational for
every child regardless of what career they
go into. Uh, the best example I make is
when I was going through high school,
every student would learn how
the digestive system works,
how a light bulb is turned
on using electricity or that
a squared plus B squared
is c squared. In many cases these
students aren't going to become, you know,
electricians or mathematicians.
It's just part of learning how the world
around us works and being well rounded.
Uh,
in today's age,
understanding what an algorithm is
or how the Internet works is equally
foundational.
These are things that students and adults
use every single day and not having
the most basic understanding
leaves people out in the dark.
I'm not the only person saying
this. Taking back to one of my, uh,
personal sort of role
models over 20 years ago,
Steve Jobs said computer
science is a liberal art.
It's something that everybody should
learn, take a year in their life,
one of the courses they take because
it teaches you how to think. Ah,
it's been 20 something
years since he said that.
And still the majority of America's
schools don't offer a single course in
computer science hat.
Last year,
President Obama also supported this call
to action saying in the new economy,
computer science is no longer an optional
skill. It's a basic skill. Uh, and again,
the problem we're trying to solve
is the majority of America schools,
whether elementary,
middle,
or high schools don't offer any computer
science courses at the other reason
this is irrelevant and this is probably
the one that is most personal to me.
And there's a,
it's harder to sort of make a case for
is to help make school fun again. Uh,
and what I say is, you know, most of
you have left school a while back.
If you look at today's students in school,
they increasingly,
it feels like they're being forced,
fed to memorize stuff that doesn't
really matter. Uh, you know,
if you're the child of a single
income ma, you know, sorry,
a single parent who's like maybe working
in a Mcdonald's and your other parent
is working in a parking lot and nobody
you knew went to college and then you're
at school memorizing the capitals of
countries you'll never visit or you know,
the histories of something from hundreds
of years ago. It just doesn't relate,
especially since most of the information
you learned in school a could do for
you.
You know,
you're learning long division in fourth
grade and you have a calculator you know,
easily that could do the same thing
as what you're learning to do. Uh,
so most kids don't find
school very engaging.
Most teachers also feel like it's this
process where there's continuous testing
and teaching to the test. The whole
school system doesn't feel very fun.
Meanwhile, computer science
is Super Fun for today's kids.
These are some examples of what students
say about using code.org to learn
computer science saying, I loved it
purely and wholly. It was fun to do.
I want to do that over and over again.
I really enjoyed what I could do with it.
I enjoyed the interactivity
and how it felt to control it.
It felt really satisfying.
I wish we could do that every day.
That's something that's, and that's
a middle school student in Idaho.
That's something that no
students says about most of
school, pretty much ever. Uh,
and so when teachers feel this,
they automatically realize
this is something slightly
different than the other
stuff they're teaching
in the classroom. Uh, or,
or a teacher from New York saying our
students have asked to have an hour every
week,
which is again the type of demand you
don't hear for most of the other courses
in the school system.
Um,
this is from a teacher in Florida
talking about AP computer science.
His students saying,
this is crazy fun.
I'm pretty much going to tell all
my friends to take this class.
And that's kids in,
in Florida talking about
taking AP computer science
that the students interest
in computer science is the most important
reason that our schools should be
offering this. Um, and then my,
this is one of my favorites is
a teacher saying that, you know,
today's project was a slam dunk.
Students came in right away and started
talking about it before the bell rang.
In fact,
when I tried to start the class,
the students that I was
trying to quiet down,
we're already talking about their project.
Uh,
we regularly hear about teachers using
coding as the sort of candy in the
classroom saying, you know, you,
you can't do the coding until you
finish your math homework or you know,
kids not wanting to go to
recess because they're so,
so engaged doing computer science.
Um,
the now a national measure of this was
actually done by a group that was trying
to uh, understand how to get students
more interested in biology. Uh,
this biology survey went out to try
and find out why aren't kids enjoying
biology? And they asked students what
are the subjects they like the most? Uh,
it turns out biology wasn't
very high on the list. Uh,
but computer science ended up being
number three just behind art and basically
music and dance. So art, music, dance.
And then computer sciences is in the
third category in terms of students most
favorite subject to learn.
Uh, which is awesome. Uh,
but it then begs the question,
if this leads to the best
paying jobs in the country,
the largest source of
economic opportunity.
And it's also among the top
favorite things kids want to learn.
Why aren't our schools teaching it?
Uh,
and that's basically the
problem that code.org has
been setting out to solve. Um,
the examples,
just this is probably easy for you to
understand why computer science is fun,
but these are examples of things students
have created in elementary school
classrooms, in middle school classrooms
or in high school classrooms.
These are basically apps that kids
make on the code.org platform.
And what's exciting
about it is for the kids,
they're making something
just like an art class.
It's something they can take home or put
on their phones and show their teachers
or show their parents and friends.
And yet at the same time to build these
things, you need to learn about angles.
You need to learn about velocity or
acceleration concepts you learned in other
classes,
but in a much more creative way.
Fundamentally, I asked for any
of the kids entering school,
especially if you envision somebody
entering kindergarten this school year,
they're going to be graduating from
university in the year 2030 what are their
career's going to look like?
I used to say that unless you want to
get a job flipping burgers or driving
trucks, he should learn
something about technology.
It turns out there's now robots that
flip burgers and trucks that drive
themselves.
There's literally not a single career
you can imagine in 2030 that's not going
to be impacted somehow by technology
and our schools should teach something
about how that technology works between
all the problems we have in America
today,
especially looking at what's happened
on the political spectrum and how much
Americans are concerned about opportunity
and the American dream and the rich
poor income divide and all
these issues in our country.
I believe if you think about our future,
teaching computer science to our students
is among the most important thing we
can do for the children.
For our children.
And what's awesome about is it's
also not politically charged.
Like many of the other things we could do.
This is something that everybody agrees
with on both sides of the aisle. Now,
unlike most nonprofits,
we don't just talk about our idea as an
opportunity or as a problem that we're
trying to solve.
A that doesn't have results were extremely
lucky to be working on something that
has incredible results and has turned
into a global teacher led movement, uh,
with frankly stunning results for
something working in education.
When I started code.org, pretty
much everybody told me, you know,
you should start a summer camp or
make an afterschool club or try to do
something online. And what they were
really saying, they weren't saying this,
they were just implicitly thinking, don't
try to change the public school system.
I think people were just
implicitly ignoring that.
We have this trillion dollar a year
system that has 50 million students in it
that never changes.
So let's figure out some end run way of
teaching computer science outside of the
school system.
And we took the approach that the
school system needs to modernize.
This is the chance to do it.
And what's enabled that has been the
teachers that support this work. Uh,
this is a picture of all the teachers
that love code.org had, I'm just kidding.
It's a rock concert. Uh, but, uh,
the reason I show this picture is the
number of teachers that support code.org
is literally a thousand times the number
of people you see in that picture.
It is truly a global movement in terms
of teachers deciding they're going to
teach computer science in their classrooms
and they are really excited about it
because for them,
they're coming from what feels like a
stodgy system that doesn't change and
they're modernizing it as well.
Um,
and this movement began with
something called an hour of code,
asking teachers globally to just
teach one hour of computer science.
And that one hour has been enough not to
learn anything other than to learn that
you can teach computer science,
even if you're a fourth grade teacher
or a seventh grade English teacher and
that your students,
even though they come from
an underprivileged background
and are struggling with
reading and writing can actually
learn coding and, and create apps.
And that learning has then sparked the
passion of hundreds of thousands of
teachers, which then caught the
attention of celebrities, CEO's,
governors and presidents of over 13
different countries and is now driving
lasting change globally.
Uh,
and what's great about this is that
this has been a grassroots bottoms up
movement.
I'm sure you've seen her.
I just showed pictures of presidents
talking about the importance of this and
we've had celebrities, tech
leaders, so on, but the,
but the strength of this movement has
really been teachers in the classrooms
deciding that this is something
their students need. Um,
this is both help change
perceptions of computer science.
It's also helped drive results as
speaking about the perceptions. Uh,
at this point,
90% of parents want their child's
school to teach computer science.
And this came from a Google
sponsored pull that Gallup did.
A 75% of Americans believe computer
science is cool in a way that it wasn't 10
years ago. Uh, so when I went to school,
computer science was the
nerdiest thing you could take.
You can frankly didn't want to tell
anybody that that's what you were spending
your time on,
just cause he'd immediately sink in the
popularity ranks in middle school or
high school. Uh, whereas now it's
actually considered to be cool. In fact,
17 magazine had a cover story about how
the cool girls are the ones that are
learning to code, which is completely
different than when I was going to school.
At this point.
The majority of parents and even the
majority of teachers believe students
should be required to
learn computer science. Uh,
and the majority of Americans rank it
right after reading and writing and math,
uh, among the top four most
important subjects to be learning a.
So everybody at this point believes
that this should be taught.
Now in terms of actual change
in the education system,
the impact we've had in four years is,
is really frankly historic.
It has never happened before.
Over 120 of the largest districts in
the country have all embraced computer
science and begun districtwide
citywide rollouts, including New York,
Los Angeles, Chicago, Miami, Las
Vegas, Houston, Broward, San Francisco,
Oakland at it where we live.
Bellevue is also on the list. Uh,
Seattle public schools is not,
although almost every public school
system around Seattle is. Uh,
and we're working on Seattle, uh, and
we'll, I'm sure we'll send, get there. Um,
over 60,000 teachers have attended
workshops to teach computer science. Uh,
this is really important to point out
because when people talk about how are we
going to get our schools to teach computer
science at the impossible way to do
it is to try to get Google engineers
to become full time teachers. Uh,
or frankly any computer
science professional.
Trying to get them to take a pay
cut from a tech, uh, you know,
profession and go into schools is hard.
And more importantly,
most Google engineers is probably
wouldn't make great teachers.
It's not easy to teach.
Uh, and then you know, you,
you don't need a Google level engineer
to teach ninth grade computer science.
We don't have surgeons teaching
ninth grade biology either.
We have science teachers doing it. Um, so,
and the things code.org
does our curriculum lowers
the bar for what a teacher
needs to know to teach computer science
and then our training workshops bring
the teachers up to that bar so they
can then be an effective teacher in a
classroom without ever having had a
computer science background in many cases,
not even having a science
or math background.
We have English teachers and social
studies teachers now teaching Ap College
Level Computer Science, uh, which is
frankly a stunning accomplishment, uh,
for the collective group that has
worked on this. Um, at this point,
20% of all students in the country have
begun coding on code.org, which is great.
And 31 states have either changed
policy or begun work towards rolling out
computer science at a statewide level
as part of their curriculum. Uh,
and this isn't just a, a national
change, it's a global change. Uh,
actually this slide is out of date.
We're already at 16 countries. Uh,
16 countries have changed their new
national curriculum and just the last four
years to add computer science.
Most of them have mandated computer
science or computational thinking to be
taught in primary school from
grades k through eight. Uh,
and there's more countries already
lining up to do the same thing.
So this level of change has,
I don't believe ever happened in the
world education system in terms of the
speed of adopting of a new course.
And this is really thanks to America's
teachers more than anything else. Uh,
you know, America doesn't
lead in education. Uh,
most countries don't look
at the u s education as the
sort of like shiny example
of something to follow. Uh,
but we do lead a technology.
This is the country that invented
the personal computer, the Internet,
the smartphones, social media,
web search, a ecommerce,
all of these things were
invented in America.
And so the countries of the world
actually look to us for leadership in this
field of education.
And so what happens in America's
classrooms is actually having much,
much broader change than
just our own country. Um,
the work we're doing@code.org
is not just building a movement.
It's also building a platform.
And by platform I mean like
a coding online platform. Uh,
so co co.org has now become one of
the fastest spreading online learning
platforms. Uh, we have roughly 10 or
20,000 students joining every day.
We have between 10 or 20,000
teachers joining every month. Uh,
my personal sort of favorite sort of role
model in the world of online learning
is Khan Academy comparing ourselves
to Khan Academy at four years old.
We're twice the size Khan Academy
was when they were six years old. Uh,
which is a great measure and we're
not competitive with Khan Academy.
We teach a very different things.
Uh,
but as a measure of something that's
basically worked its way into classrooms,
we're doing fantastically well.
Uh,
and the reason is the stuff
we do is designed to enable
students and teachers to
start coding and creating
immediately without prior experience,
without needing to install eclipse.
Or some other thing on your computer
and on any modern browser without even
needing to know how to type
or even knowing how to read
and write so we can meet
students at any level of experience.
Even a preschool or kindergarten
students can start coding. Um,
and all of this, the work that we've
done is free and it's open source.
And as a result of that has become the
number one platform and curriculum for
teaching computer science in k
through 12 all around the world. Uh,
I want to do some quick demos to
give you a sense of the technology,
but I want to see a quick show of hands.
How many people here have seen
coding on code.org before?
All right,
so I'm going to do two quick demos,
but one of them will be short
because you probably have seen it,
some version of this before.
So the first is our,
one of our hour of code tutorials.
And this just gives you a sense of
why our curriculum is different than
traditional curriculum.
How the way we combine the ide,
where you do the coding with the videos
that teach you about it and the sort of
instruction on what you're supposed to do.
Um,
the first thing is just the fact that
we have star wars as one of the brands
supporting us is pretty cool.
Uh,
the fact that we can have a video that
has an opening sequence like this, uh,
and this audience doesn't work.
MMM.
Um,
so I'm not going to play for the video,
but the video tutorials,
we have basically how people like the
crater of the star wars movie and all the
women who actually played a role in
making the star wars movie teach this
tutorial just to emphasize the
importance of women in computing. Uh,
and then the code you need to write
is to control the little robot.
And you have ray, who's the, the heroine
of the new movie telling you, you know,
you need to write the code to
get this little BB eight guy.
Let me see if I can make this bigger.
So you need to get BBA to
get to that scrap metal.
And this is a very simple problem.
You just need to move them
to steps to the right.
These are the four types of commands he
could do, which was very limited. Uh,
and his code right now is he
can, when he runs, he moves,
right one step and I'm going
to just have him move up,
which is not the right
thing and then move down
and then move right?
Again,
that was not very complicated,
but for if you've never,
ever done any coding before,
that is so much more fun and
easy than install visual studio.
And then,
you know,
figuring out what sub routines you need
to include and like what libraries you
need and then compile and then how do you,
what you need to do.
And then it also shows you, this is the
javascript for the code that you made.
This,
as many of you may know,
is based on the open source blockly
sub routines that uh, uh, the,
the blockly source code that
Google has helped us with.
One thing I was also really exciting when
we launched this tutorial was being to
say that we were using
intellectual property by Disney,
open source code by Google funding,
by Microsoft running on Amazon's web
servers showcase in every apple store. Uh,
there's so few things that have this many
otherwise competitors working together
on one problem. Uh, and
this tutorial has been done.
I'm not going to walk through all 15
steps or the different puzzles you walk
through,
but after 15 steps in about 30 minutes,
you can make your own game featuring
r two d two getting chased by storm
troopers are running
after the storm troopers.
You can write your own rules and then
play it on your phone. Um, and these,
these one hour tutorials are super fun.
Uh,
but we've built a complete ide for
building much more complicated things.
And I want to give you an example
of how that works outside of, uh,
sort of curriculum. So this here is
our ID. That's called APP lab. Uh,
it's over here.
You can create an APP and I'm going to
show you really quickly how it works. Um,
so I'm gonna make my app,
I'm first going to put a
background color on the screen.
So she was like a blue color.
And then
can I put a label here
that says my drawing APP?
Okay,
can y'all see that? And then I'm
going to put a piece of texts,
a text box here saying to, to ask
somebody, what should we draw?
I'm going to say enter a number of
sides and I'll put a button to draw.
I'm kind of rushing through this.
It doesn't look very good, but okay,
so we have a little app that if I click
the draw button, it'll draw a shape.
And so I need to attach some code
to this so I can go into code mode.
And then I can say on
event when I get an event,
and any of you are familiar
with the document object model,
know that this isn't the
full document object model.
There's no such thing as an on event call.
Uh, but you know, I can say, you know,
when the button is clicked,
I can start writing some code.
And so I need to figure out how
many sides my shape needs to be.
So I'm going to set a variable to that
sort of x will be the variable that keeps
that uh, an x. We'll
get the number of sides.
So I need to get the text from this thing.
So at the text for that is the
text that's in text input one.
So now we want to draw an x sided shape,
uh,
for that I'm going to need a for loop.
So here's a four loop.
And so as I'm doing this, you probably
recognize what this looks like.
Even though these are blocks, you can
actually switch and see this in text mode.
And this is basically you're typing
in Java script seminar account.
I goes from zero and it should go up to x.
And so x times I want to draw a line at
and we have turtle drawing commands to
make this easy.
So I can say move forward and I can drag
blocks interior even if I don't want to
type.
So I'll move forward,
let's say 50 pixels and
then I'll turn right.
And this will need to be 360 divided
by x degrees to get to x sided shape.
And so this is a very simple app.
I can now run my app and say
I want a five sided shape.
Yeah,
it should draw a Pentagon. So not super
amazing, but it was relatively fast.
I don't need to create an account,
I don't need to install anything and I
can share this and I can send it to my
phone.
This is probably the best part about this
for students and the speed at which we
can let you create something
and then get it on your phone
is what really makes this
magical for students. So this is,
I basically set myself a text message
and you probably can't see my phone,
but just from the color you
might be able to recognize it.
It's the same thing with the little text
box in Soma and basically does exactly
that on your phone, uh,
for prototyping in school.
The other solutions for doing something
like this takes so much effort at and
this base, he shows by making coding
easy, accessible, web based free.
We've made it much, much easier for
students and teachers to engage with us.
And this is just like five minutes
of showing what this looks like.
We've made literally 400 hours worth of
exercise and activities starting from
kindergarten all the way through a high
school AP computer science to make this
stuff easier.
The reason code.org has become so big
is because we've lowered the bar so much
for schools to engage in computer
science. Um, we act very small.
We're a 60 person startup and
our DNA is like a tech company.
So we act small but we think really big.
Um,
and as a result of this shows that the
growth of AP computer science in schools,
which is the college board exam,
which is basically the pinnacle of the
computer science sort of a learning
pathway.
This current school year that just ended
was our first time teaching AP computer
science in schools.
Uh,
and that's basically what AP computer
science looks like after the first year of
code.org teaching the course. Uh, and
since we care a lot about diversity,
this is what the picture looks like
for women in computer science and for
underrepresented minorities in
computer science. In both cases,
we more than doubled participation in the
AP program in just our very first year
of teaching it next year.
I expect we will more than double it
relative to where we were last year. Uh,
yet again,
uh,
just because our growth this coming
year is more than double our growth from
last year. Uh, so the,
the impact we're having in terms of
the entire computer science pathways,
not only getting students
into try and computer science,
but getting all the way to
teaching basically college
level computer science to
kids in public schools.
Uh,
and I want to say something about
diversity because you know, when,
when I look around this room and when
you look anywhere in the tech world,
diversity is a problem.
And that problem is partly because of
the cultural issues in the workplace,
issues that we all hear about.
But a huge part of it is also what
happens in the education pipeline that our
education system has almost the exact
same diversity challenges in computer
science.
Traditionally computer science has been
a 80% male dominated and more than 80%
non basically white Asian or Indian
dominated field in k through 12 as well as
in university as well as in the workplace.
The work code.org has been
doing is in every school,
particularly with a focus
on urban and rural schools,
which have the most underprivileged kids.
And as a result of that,
our students are very different from,
uh,
from what you see in the traditional
workforce. So, uh, in our classrooms,
the classrooms are 45% female.
They're almost 50%
underrepresented minorities.
And something that people don't talk very
much is how many of them are poor kids.
47% of them are kids who can't even afford
lunch and they're learning coding and
computer science. Uh, and if you
look at our kids taking the AP exam,
even passing the AP exam,
there's similar numbers that are female
percentage on the AP exam is lower.
But our percentage of minorities and
basically a less affluent kids taking AP
computer science is matching the,
the entire country's diversity.
This is a fantastic story for
opportunity and diversity.
It'll change what our workplaces look
like in the tech industry and it's really
giving a pathway to these kids who
otherwise wouldn't have won. Uh,
studies show that women are 10 times
more likely to take a computer science if
they studied in high school.
Black and Hispanic kids are eight times
more likely to study it in university if
they take it in high
school. And in fact, uh,
black and Hispanic students are more
interested in learning computer science
then white students are, they're just
less likely to have it in their schools.
And as a result,
they never tried in high school and then
they never go into it to university,
which is why the k through 12 system is
where to make this change. Um, in general,
I believe the American dream is really
a global ideal for opportunity for all.
And every one of us is here
where we are because we caught a
break@somepointinourlivesandtheworkofcode.org
is
basically
helping
bring
that
level of opportunity to the kids who
need it the most in America at schools.
I think that's it.
But I lastly wanted to close by thanking
the very generous donors who support
our work. Uh, you know, we, we wouldn't
be anywhere. We are without the,
the various corporations and
individuals who support us.
Google is one of our largest supporters.
Uh,
and we've been very lucky to have Google
support since the very beginning. Uh, so,
uh, thank you very much for your part of
your work is helping feed co.org through
the generous work that you
do. Um, thank you very much.
Uh,
please [inaudible].
Uh, I would like to ask [inaudible]
to join us for the panel discussion.
Thank you,
honey.
All right. Um, I want to thank Heidi. Um,
I think that is just one of
the most inspirational, uh, uh,
you know, real life
stories. It's, it's amazing.
I have the privilege of having worked
for Heidi, uh, over a decade ago. And,
uh,
I was there when he started this and
I am absolutely amazed at what he has
accomplished and the level of depth and
passion that you guys can see in how
he's speaking about the subject.
It's,
it's really amazing to have a global
impact in such a short amount of time.
So thank you, Heidi.
Thank you. Um, so, uh,
first I'd like to start with, you
know, why did you start code.org?
Okay,
so this is actually an interesting
thing, which I would say, um,
I didn't start code.org thinking I want
to change the world's education system,
which would be a very
arrogant thing to think. Uh,
I just wanted to make a video.
It's to say that computer science is
important and I was at the time kind of
unemployed and not really doing
anything of value and just thought,
what can I do that's useful with my time?
Uh, I didn't make sort of a home movie.
I kind of used all of my best connections
from two decades of working in the
tech industry.
So I managed to get Bill Gates and
Mark Zuckerberg and Jack Dorsey to
participate in this video.
So it was a pretty big affair,
but it was just one video and I had no
plans for what would be coming beyond the
video.
I thought I'd put out this great video
that computer science is important in
schools should teach it.
Uh, the video went viral,
not only to get 10 million views,
more importantly,
20,000 schools reached out and said,
we want this.
And that's what made me realize if
20,000 schools respond to one video,
there's just a real interest
in this. Um, but the, uh,
the personal reason I got into it,
it's just because of my life
story of success in tech. Uh,
but what I love telling people
about this is really, you know,
this did not start as a big plan or
this flash of genius or anything.
Uh,
and considering that in four years,
so much of the world education system
has changed starting from this one little
video.
Anybody for me has really drilled home
this idea that if you have a big dream,
if you work hard at it, I'm an
aim big, anything is possible.
I think many people's ambitions,
uh,
are held back by their fear
of trying for something.
And sometimes if you aim extra high,
you actually have a greater chance of
succeeding because more people want to
support you.
Thank you. Heidi. Phil, I know you
were also involved in the early days.
We'd love to hear your story.
I'd like to tell a little bit, um, um,
because I hope that you all will will
also join me in comport computed,
uh,
supporting cs education and uh,
this is a potential area of growth
for the Kirkland campus. So, uh,
I too had worked with Hadi.
I have always been super impressed
by the way he approaches things,
including the way he approached a CS
education, which is, it's a nonprofit,
but it really does work like a startup.
And, um, he's been incredibly driven.
So,
um,
initially my involvement was helping him
launch the website around the video and
start to establish connections
with people. Um, and, um,
that was just really incredibly rewarding
to be able to help out a little bit
for this. Um, I, I also felt a
strong need to want to give back.
I mean we,
we've all been really lucky and for this
country to continue to be successful or
for Google to continue to be successful,
we need everybody to have
opportunities and do well. Um,
beyond that,
I had the great fortune to work with
code.org for a year helping them scale for
hour of code.
They'd been tremendously successful as
such that they're scaling pressure on the
website. So I helped them
with some technical and team
improvements to the site.
And this is an example
of how Google is really,
really far sighted about this. They
gave one of their engineers to, to help,
um, a nonprofit that they
support it, um, to, to succeed,
not for short term profit concerns
because they knew this was about making
Google successful for the long term and
about making society successful. Um,
beyond that, starting in
September, I'm joining edge edu.
This is the organization within Google
that supports both internal, uh,
CS education,
which you've probably seen in some of
the classes if you've taken the machine
learning bootcamp or something like that.
They do that,
but they also support external
education. Uh, that includes the,
the blockly framework
that code.org uses a,
that includes some of the funding efforts,
um,
as well as platforms that Google is
building to help promote CS education in
general. Um, so I, uh,
there are already several,
um, program managers and non engineers
and Kirkland working on this.
Um, I will be the first engineer. We
do have an open head count. So if,
if cs education is something you're
excited about, a police talk with me.
All right, well thank you. Fell. Um, hi.
I know you've made a pretty
convincing case about this already,
but I'd love to hear from you why you
think all students need to learn to code.
So this is a question we get all the time.
Um,
usually with a more critical
version of delivery,
people regularly say,
you know, why are we,
why should we teach third graders
how to code? Or, you know,
not every kid is going to become a coder.
And this is something that
is often viewed as, you know,
code.org is trying to get people into
tech jobs or something like that. Uh,
and I usually say we're not trying
to get every kid to learn to code.
We're trying to get every school
to teach computer science,
which is very different. Uh, computer
science is much more broad than coding.
W The only reason we're called code.org
is because we wanted the shortest URL
possible. Otherwise we would have been
schools to teach computer science.org.
Uh, but, uh,
computer science includes things like
learning how does the Internet work or how
to keep your computer safe on the
internet or big data and data analysis.
And when you think about that, those
types of things, how networks work,
these are much broader
than just learning to code.
And every school should
offer them, uh, you know,
just data analysis type of thing that
almost every 21st century jobs at a need,
some version of that staying
safe on the Internet, every,
every child can benefit from.
And as soon as you realize the
broader view of computer science,
the idea of having schools that don't
teach it suddenly seems really short.
Shortsighted.
Who Do you feel like teaching
computer science? Um,
when our teachers are
struggling to teach the basics.
How do you think that we can,
I know you have amazing statistics in
terms of the teachers that have joined the
force in terms of teaching computer
science, but you know, as you know, it's,
it's easier to grow small numbers.
What do you think it takes
to bring it to the masses?
I'm one the teachers are struggling with
a lot of the basics in our education
system. Yup. Yup.
Our education system is not great.
I should start by saying, um,
nobody looks at the US education system
no matter who you are and thinks this is
just amazing.
Every country should do it this way.
Most of the teachers and the education
system don't feel that way either.
It's a system that just feels kind of
left behind or improperly tended or so on,
schools or short on budgets. There's
just all sorts of issues in our country.
Make teaching also harder as well because
kids come to school with all sorts of
home issues that they bring and so on.
So our schools are struggling and our
teachers are struggling there frankly on
the front lines of trying to help
a lot of kids get to a better path.
People regularly asked me,
can these kids who are struggling to
learn reading and writing and the teachers
who were not able to get them to
pass basic graduation requirements,
can they learn computer science?
Uh,
and I actually be believed that teaching
computer science in the schools can
actually help rather than make it
harder because it can make school more
engaging and more relevant.
And I made this point earlier
about making school more fun. Uh,
it's not something that
the adults necessarily know
cause they didn't themselves
study computer science so they
don't even know what it's about.
But once they try it in the classroom
and they see how engaged the kids are,
it actually makes a difference
for the rest of school.
And we've had so many stories about this
that a wonderful, just a few weeks ago,
one of our, not not
weeks, a few months ago,
one of our teachers wrote in about a
student that had stopped coming to school
in ninth grade and four
47 school days straight.
This student just stopped coming.
Imagine a ninth grader who just for
two months no longer comes to school.
That kid, if that, if that
continues, their life is on a very,
very different path than,
than anybody here. Um,
and then the teacher
wrote into the dad saying,
we're about to start this new computer
science pilot with code.org could you
have your kid come and try that?
Maybe. Maybe they'll like it.
And not only the kid liked it,
the kid has now stayed in school and
he literally credits the fact that he's
learning coding for the reason he
was coming at school. That's a,
that's an extreme example of a kid who
otherwise would basically be lost in our
society to now they're, you know,
they're back in school again.
But that that small dynamic is a microcosm
of what lots of students feel because
computer science is more relevant to them.
Then trigonometry or Middle
Eastern history or you know,
learning languages and countries,
they'll never visit her.
A lot of the other things that we have
to memorize in school just to pass tests.
So how do you feel we can
help our teachers? You know,
it feels like they're really critical
to do the vision behind code.org.
As you said,
it's a teacher led movement.
How do you think we can
actually help our teachers?
We do a lot of things to help teachers
are our main customer@code.org as
teachers,
you know,
for any tech startup it's important
to know who is your customer.
And for us it could be the the students
or the parents or the policy makers or
whatnot. But teachers are our
most important customer. Uh,
everything we do is focused on how to
make teachers more successful and more
appreciated. And appreciation is
actually a really important thing. Um,
teachers generally feel underpaid,
disrespected and unappreciated in America.
Uh,
part of why code.org has been
successful is because we are,
we continuously lavish our teachers
with praise for the work that they do.
And they noticed that because nobody
else lavish them with praise. Uh,
but then we also help them with all
sorts of little things. Um, you know,
for example,
the fact that you don't need to create
an account to do the hour of code makes
it just one step easier. Um, we
even do things like, you know,
we have a lot of unplugged activities
that don't require a computer. Uh,
but they require stuff. For example,
we, we teach kids how to do sorting,
uh, you know, sorting algorithms by giving
kids a deck of cards and then, you know,
telling them to get together
in a group and put the,
put the deck in order and then
come back and say how you did it.
And it's a nice way of learning,
just trying a sorting algorithm
and then explaining what you did.
You're kind of putting your
mind into algorithmic thinking.
But one of the ways we help our teachers
is we shipped the ducks have cards to
them so they don't need to go to the
store and basically by the deck of cards
from their own salaries.
So teachers who teach our courses,
they could get basically like a box of
the deck of multiple decks of cards,
some paper cups,
like a bunch of little stuff they need
to get like all the shopping they would
otherwise need to do.
They literally get it from code.org in
fact where we ship $500,000 a year of
stuff like that to classrooms basically
just to save the teachers the hassle
because if they had to buy the decks of
cards themselves, many of them wouldn't.
And they wouldn't teach that that exercise
cause they just don't have the time
or money to do it.
The little things really matter.
Yeah. That's amazing. It's everything
that you guys have done. It's,
it seems like you paid attention to a
water of the little details that add a lot
of convenience. Um, so I'm curious
if we add computer science,
what should it replace in the curriculum?
Yeah,
this is a about controversial question.
I might give my mom global
answer just in this room.
I'll first tell you the diplomatic
answer. Um, because there's actually,
you can add computer science without
replacing a ton. In most cases.
In elementary school,
you don't really need to replace
anything because it's so much fun. Uh,
if you imagine like the
second grade classroom,
if any of you have kids in second grade,
kids aren't learning every hour. Math,
science, English, history, you know,
you have to interrupt their class time
with play time just to keep them engaged.
You know,
it's like 20 minutes of reading and
outlets like dance and then then like 20
minutes of math and now let's
sing and you need to mix it up.
That up for the students.
And coding actually fits into the
fun category in elementary school,
which is very, very different. It's not
what the students are teachers expect,
but once they do it,
they realize actually we don't need
to fit it in because of that. Um,
in middle school,
what computer science typically can
replace is outdated tech ed courses.
Every school added Tech Ed to their
middle school programs starting in the
eighties or nineties,
and what they're still teaching today,
there's middle school courses in most
schools teaching how to browse the web,
how to do Internet search, you know,
things like that. And everybody doing it.
The teacher's like, all right, kids,
now we're going to learn how to browse
the web. And the kids were like,
I already know how to do this. What should
I do? And the teacher's like, I dunno,
like, you know, it's, it's that
system wants something to replace it,
which is why schools come to us asking,
what can we replace this crappy
course with? Uh, they actually,
part of the demand we get is
because they realize they're,
they're teaching something outdated.
Um,
in high school you don't need to
replace anything because in high school
students choose what they get to take.
Uh,
so as long as you make a computer
science available for one hour a day,
as long as 25 students enroll,
that hour is full.
That teacher salaries paid for some
other course lost its, you know,
its students and some other
courses we'll have one less hour.
It's being taught in the school needs
to shuffle around the teachers some, uh,
but you don't need to replace something.
And in fact,
what schools regularly find is 50
students sign up and then you need to two
hours a day dedicated to computer science.
And basically the students are choosing
what to replace by voting with their
feet in the schools that
teach computer science.
It's the fastest growing of course
in terms of student enrollment. Uh,
and so students are deciding whatever
it is that they're choosing not to have
time.
I'm curious.
One thing that was surprising to me is
certainly when I went to school, um,
I nobody thought computer
science was fun. Um, and I'm,
I was fascinated by the
stats you sharing. Um, how,
how has that switch happened? I mean,
as a little bit of a chicken and egg,
which is until you try it and you
get the instant gratification,
you don't realize it's fun.
So how do you get students
to try in order for them to,
to realize there's a whole new
world of opportunity there?
Sure.
Um,
the biggest change has been when I
studied computer science and probably when
you did it and probably what most people
in this room study computer science, uh,
the curriculum had been designed I
think from the math establishment,
which isn't bad or wrong,
but it's definitely a more
narrow view of computer science.
As an example, I remember having to
learn recursion and to learn recursion,
I had to write the code to calculate
the FIBONACCI sequence and it's like
recursion is cool,
but the FIBONACCI sequence sucks.
Like who cares about the
FIBONACCI sequence? Uh,
unless you're a math guy and you think
about the patterns and leaves and things
like that, but like it's a
very narrow use of recursion.
You could teach recursion by making a
cool fractal, which is, and then you like,
you're much more likely to show a
fractal to your mom then the Fibonacci
sequence and your mom would be much more
likely to get excited about the fractal
then about a bunch of numbers.
Um,
so the creativity of what the
course is actually teach is,
I think the most important reason,
uh, computer science is more fun.
And that's partly about
changing curriculum.
It's also partly because kids
now have phones and you know,
that little thing I showed you, you can
make something and get it on your phone.
That wasn't possible. Uh, when, when
I was learning computer science,
you have a question,
question of all the amazing
stats you showed to me.
The one that's most amazing is the one
about the number of kids with free and
reduced lunch because that seems very
counter to what I would think that those
kids are in schools where
they tend to have less money,
less ability to buy the infrastructured
by the, the computers for them to use.
So I was curious if you could talk
a little bit about how and why,
what you need to do to get a stat like
that and some of your philosophy behind
that. Sure. Um, by the way,
Larry works a bit at Code Dot Archies
his 20% time project I'd Google is to
volunteer for us.
And we were very thankful for his time at.
So in terms of the,
the questions you asked,
the first thing I'd say is
that the majority of schools
have adequate computing
and Internet access infrastructure
to be able to teach computer science.
Most schools don't have one
to one computing in order
to teach math on computers
because every student takes math
every day of every school year. Uh,
and so you'd need every kid
to have their own computer.
If you want to move math and English and,
and sort of those fields onto computers,
you need way more computers and
way more Internet bandwidth.
Computer Science is either taught in
elementary school one hour a week,
which means the kids cycle through
it or it's, if it's in high school,
it's an optional class and
not every student takes it.
And so you need about 30 computers for
every thousand kids and 90 something,
96% of schools have that
and they're internet. Uh,
it's not all schools, but other
than the 4% that don't have that,
most schools have adequate computing
infrastructure and our stuff we work go
through the trouble of making sure it
works on older computers with smaller
resolutions and things like that.
Uh,
the other thing that's,
that's counterintuitive that people
don't expect cause they're stereotypes is
this.
I think there's a stereotype that kids
in these underprivileged schools are less
capable and it's not true at all.
They're there,
especially if you get to
them young. Um, in fact,
we just did data analysis of
our AP computer science course,
which is the college level course
comparing the diversity in our computer
science classroom to the diversity of
the entire school itself. Uh, you know,
so if the school had 60%
underrepresented kids,
what percentage in our classroom we're,
you know,
black or Hispanic students versus
a school that had 20%. And, uh,
if we plotted every school on this map
and they almost perfectly lined up with
the, uh, the line of basically,
you know, a slope, one line,
meaning diversity in our computer science
classrooms matched at the diversity of
the school from a, from a
race standpoint. Uh, and,
and this really gets to the point that
the issue we have is access in schools
that don't teach computer science.
None of those kids are learning in the
schools that do teach computer science.
The representation matches both racial
diversity and socioeconomic diversity of
the students. Gender diversity
is harder. Gender diversity,
kids stereotypes, mess with
them. And the girls, Cinco,
this course isn't for me because you know,
I,
from all the movies I've watched the
people doing that are like these white 18
year old boys in a dark basement with
an energy drink and a star wars poster.
And like, that's not me and I
don't want to live that life. Uh,
and that holds back a
lot of women, uh, but on,
on socioeconomic diversity
and racial diversity,
it's much more that they just literally
don't have it in their classroom.
And so they don't get the chance.
Shiny.
That room here is curious to know
how can Google, there's health,
there's lots of ways Googlers can
help. Uh, if you look on our website,
there's a button called help us,
uh, or it's code.org/help. Uh,
the easiest way to help is to follow us
on Facebook or Twitter and to retweet
the stuff we share.
Uh,
the next easiest ways to
buy one of our hats or,
or socks.
We have code like a girl shirts that
are super cool and very popular.
Just buying our swag. Uh, it doesn't
make as much money when you do that,
but if you wear them,
it helps spread the idea that computer
science is something that everybody
should do.
Uh,
but there's many other ways and there's
a list of them at donating to us is
always appreciated.
Uh,
telling google.org to continue supporting
us as a very important, uh, you know,
Google's foundation branch,
google.org as one of our top supporters
and the way they decide where to give
money. A lot of that comes from
feedback from Googlers. Uh, you know,
most corporations make their
decisions top down as, you know,
Google's decisions are made in this sort
of weird neural network kind of way. Uh,
and, and literally when we
talked to the folks@google.org,
they talk about whether they're hearing
about code.org from the, you know,
the hive mind of Google.
So however that works,
if you could communicate to the foundation
side of the hive mind that you're
excited about their support
for Google dot for code.org ad,
that would be really helpful as well.
I guess similarly,
how can technology companies health more
holistically other than the individual
technology employees?
Financial support is a
really big part of it.
And Google is not our top supporter. I
think they're number four or five. Uh,
but the work we do costs real money,
uh, and, and that really matters,
you know, uh, but then employee
volunteering is also super helpful.
Uh,
there's a page code.org/health which
lists these things and one of them is the
signup as a volunteer to basically help
teachers and classrooms and inspire
students. Uh, and, and that's
another great way as well.
Um, so I've been told to wrap
it up. Um, and, uh, how do you,
I'll just leave it up to you
for your closing words. Um,
and I think that would be
the best use of our time.
Okay. Um, I'll stick around if
there's any other questions.
The one thing I'd say in closing,
and I kind of said this already as it's
been unreal that our education system
has changed to embrace computer science
at the pace it has. And in fact, every,
almost every week or two weeks,
I,
I still need to remind myself
that this is actually happening.
One crazy example of this is just the
very recent momentum in just the last six
weeks for entire countries decided to
do national rollouts of computer science
for their entire country, uh,
almost one country every week.
And it's been hard for us to even keep
up on reporting the news because it
changes so quickly. Uh, but that,
that change is entirely
because of teachers deciding
that this is important and
doing it in a grassroots way at,
and this is really one of the best
stories I think in America today.
We were living in this weird divided time.
Our country is in a bit of a funk.
Uh,
I don't think there's as
many very Americans who think
that America is sort of,
you know, all it could be,
you're doing super great,
but what we're doing in
America's classrooms with
computer science is incredibly
great, and it's not just helping America.
It's really helping changing the world.
And that's something I think every
American could be very proud of.
Thank you for joining us.
Really appreciate everything you've done.